un loup jamais rassasié une histoire de
caroline guilleminot illustré par
modeste madoré aux éditions jalane
publication
c'est l'histoire d'un loup qui n'était
jamais rassasié c'était plus fort que
lui il avait tout le temps faim et ils
manger et manger
il mangeait il dévorait de gros sanglier
des cochons gr.d petit chaperon rouge il
avalé tout ce qu'ils trouvaient il
fallait pas se trouver sur son chemin
car on était sûr d'être mangés tout cru
d'ailleurs tous les habitants de la
forêt avaient peur de lui et s'enfuyait
dès qu'il le voyait un jour alors qu'il
avait comme d'habitude très très faim et
qu'il se baladait dans la forêt le loup
senti au loin une odeur délicieuse odeur
de fraise des bois et de mûres sauvages
une odeur une odeur de rose et de foin
coupé une odeur insupportablement
insupportable qui lui mis l'eau à la
bouche
quel était donc ce parfum que l'on santé
à dix mille lieues à la ronde
il n'avait jamais renifler quelque chose
comme ça alléchés par l'odeur le loup
décida de découvrir ce qui sentait si
bon même s'il fallait parcourir des
kilomètres
le loup traversa un bois de noisetiers
en jambe à un lac aux eaux argenté il
sauta par dessus une et de noisetiers
dit à l'ats dans un champ de tournesols
dépasse à un verger et arriva enfin dans
une clairière
ils étaient essoufflés et bien sur cette
course lui avait donné faim très faim
une feinte de vous sur la pointe des
pâtes le vous s'avance à la un singe une
marmotte des poules et plein d'autres
bêtes discuter joyeusement autour d'une
longue table
ce n'était que rires et cris de joie
monsieur leloup venez n'ayez pas peur
dit le blaireau fait nous l'honneur par
do répondit le loup stupéfait ce blé
rouge bien culotté ans at-il mais c'est
moi le long qui devrait leur faire peur
se dit il tout bas seulement ils étaient
affamés et il ne supportait pas les
contrariétés quand il allait manger cela
pouvait lui couper l'appétit
le loup s'approcha donc et posa ses
pattes sur le rebord de la table il
tourna la tête à gauche à droite puis
encore à gauche et à droite qu'il y
avait sur la table le chatouiller
vraiment les narines délicieusement
d'ailleurs là au milieu de la table se
trouvait d'immenses plat d'argent là des
choses à manger était rangé par couleur
tout avait l'air très appétissants à
droite envoyé de drôles de pâte verte
comme les prêts à côté une mousse
d'avocats étaient parsemer de ciboulette
à gauche des fraises rouge vif était
posé sur un lit de tomates et de fleurs
de radis à droite encore des lamelles de
champignons blancs ornés de fromage
frais de la purée de pommes de terre
formaient une montagnes plus hautes que
le mont blanc en guise de drapeau
un joli plumeau en asperge été posée au
sommet à gauche encore un gratin de
citrouilles dorée à souhait fumer fumée
fumée des fleurs de capucine sauvages et
des quartiers de mandarine forme est une
magnifique guirlandes orange et du jaune
du bleu du vert du viol et une multitude
de couleurs bonnes à manger
c'est donc cela si le loup cette odeur
délicieuse que j'ai senti dans la forêt
c'est celle de tous ses plats goûtés
goûtez donc s'exclama le blaireau je
peux vraiment et si tu as le loup bien
sûr monsieur leloup vous êtes notre
invité rétorque quel blaireau et le loup
pic aura
grignota et savoura cette nourriture de
toutes les couleurs il n'avait pas que
des crocs il avait aussi une langue une
langue pour goûter le salé le sucré
l'acidulé qu'une régal depuis ce jour le
loup est devenu très gourmands ont dit
qu'ils préparent des plats absolument
délicieux pour tous ses nouveaux amis il
paraît même que c'est un grand cuisinier
c'est un secret